there's horseback riding there's red
rock canyon for that you can land sail
down in the the flats outside of las
vegas there's so much to see so much to
explore across nevada there is i'm a
hiker i love getting out there this is a
great state bianca holman joining us
live with john burke with places you
could check out outdoors good morning
all right hey good morning heather good
morning john so heather i'm kind of like
you i like hiking and you heard from
john burke a little bit earlier about
all the different spots you can check
out either with your family some hidden
gems or even if you are an adventurer
so we're also talking about longboarding
one of those activities that you can do
outdoors so shane ramban come on over
with
your group that you skate with and tell
us what's the difference between
longboarding and skateboarding there is
a subtle difference though yeah
skateboarding is usually about tricks
and longboarding is a little bit more
about cruising and just kind of surfing
the cement and mellow mellow carving and
you were telling us you know with our
weather here we're pretty much we can do
things outdoors year round
what have been some of the cool spots
that you've been able to long board at
around around our state there's a lot of
great skate parks around this vegas area
this one craig ranch so this is anthem
and then craig ranch skate park is great
we also enjoy bike paths and a lot of
mellow neighborhoods there's a lot of
longboarding is great because you can do
it anywhere it doesn't have to be in a
specific area yeah and you were telling
me i mean he showed me how to get on so
you're going to show me
y'all i'm just going to get on the board
and he's going to pull me along okay so
break down how do i get on the board all
right so you want to usually put your
front foot on first okay
and then you can put your back foot on
yep that's good and keep your feet
perpendicular okay there you go and then
we're going to go start going a little
bit and i got to hold on to him i'm
holding on to him really tight yeah a
little there you go okay and then lean
towards me
towards a little bit this is an
unflattering position i can just see it
let's go back the other direction okay
all right
hold on
that was a trick that was a trick you
guys all right grab the mic
and we're going and we're going okay i
can stop i'm nervous okay shane grab it
grab it
all right he's the expert okay i don't
claim to to be an expert with this but i
will try new things but thank you so
much shane and again you said where's
the spot that you say long borders if
they're out there and they're watching
this where they got to go skate at
across the state it could be anywhere
anywhere across the state i would say um
i said go out and explore that's the
thing about longboarding is you can you
can longboard anywhere if you see a
smooth street go out and hit it just
have fun that's what it's all about all
right yes i had fun
i had fun i had fun
let's send it back to you guys in the
studio i don't claim to be a longboarder
but i will try anything y'all know that
and
thank you shane i got him i'm glad
bianca you couldn't you could have
fooled us bianca i don't know
actually no i gotta get props to the
photographer because he made sure he
wasn't right behind you so yeah
okay good job he made me look good you
look good i wasn't sure if armando had a
good angle on me and you're good you
looked great
thank you